before i close out the book see stories
there's one one
one other little section i wanted to
cover it's from a it's from a chapter
called
the greatest the next greatest
generation
and this this takes this section takes
place in 2007
we mentioned that you were in europe for
a time you're in charge of all special
operations forces
in europe and africa but that means
you're actually over in germany most of
the time
and in this part you're visiting wounded
soldiers
on their way home from iraq and
afghanistan so on the way home from iraq
and afghanistan oftentimes
the the soldiers the wounded would be
would stop in germany
and at launch duel and you would go
there to visit these
wounded guys and um you talk about one
of these
one of these cases here so you're going
in to visit
going to the book the doctor nodded and
i pushed
the door open and entered lying on the
bed completely naked was a young soldier
not more than 25 years old
his body was swollen from the impact of
the blast burns covered the upper half
of his torso
and below his waist he had lost half of
one leg and much of the other
his face was so badly damaged that his
eyes were almost sealed shut
and his lips burned clean off
life-saving tubes extended from just
about every orifice
in his body and monitors around the room
beeped continuously
sir he can't talk but he can hear you
and he likes to engage people the doctor
said
i slowly walked up beside the bed
hey partner my name's admiral mcraven
i could see him acknowledge my presence
you look like [ __ ] he managed to smile
and reached out his hand
toward the nightstand the doctor grabbed
a clipboard and handed it to the soldier
he likes to write out his responses the
doctor said
pulling the attached pen from its holder
he scribbled on the notepad
you should see the other guy
i laughed and he chuckled with me looks
like they're taking good care of you
is there anything you need once again he
grabbed the clipboard
and wrote a beer
the doctor looked at me and reluctantly
shook his head well i'll tell you what
when you get back to the states get well
and the beer is on me he just nodded
i was struggling with what to say i had
been in these situations hundreds of
times before
and all you could do is make small talk
normally i knew the soldier or his unit
and i had something more significant to
offer i walked around to the doctor's
side of the bed
is he a marine or a soldier i whispered
to the doctor
sir i don't know i'm just the attending
physician i can find out for you though
no not necessarily not necessary walking
back around to my side of the bed i
leaned over to the young man and asked
are you a marine or a soldier he seemed
agitated by the question he pointed to a
tattoo that was etched on his thigh he
must have assumed that the tattoo is
fully visible
but the blast had burned the legs so
badly that only a smudged outline
appeared
i looked closely and could see the image
of a big red one
the first infantry division you're a
soldier
i commented he grabbed the clipboard
infantry he wrote
infantry the toughest occupation in the
army i thought
the soldiers are always marching always
carrying a rucksack
always in the line of fire you have to
be strong and fit
to last in any infantry unit
particularly during war
as i glanced at the young man's battered
body i wondered if he fully understood
the degree of his injuries
he noticed me assessing his physical
condition and suddenly
a look of defiance came across his
swollen face he rolled in my direction
and then wrote slowly in capital letters
i will be infantry again
so that's um you know like you said
something that you witnessed hundreds of
times and
and one thing that you write in the
books and i've heard you talk about it
as well
is with all these
wounded soldiers that you've you know
soldiers sailors airmen and marines that
you've gone and talked to
every single one of them every single
one of them
has just wanted to get back to their
unit and get back in the fight
yeah and you've been there you you know
that and it is remarkable to me
and i think of the to your point you
know hundreds of these guys that i've
met never once
did i hear anybody complain i mean guys
that lost arms and legs and blast
victims
and they didn't complain
it's just amazing to me i i don't know
if i tell the story in that book but
i've told the story
before when i was socom commander i went
up
to to walter reed and i used to do it
periodically same thing when the guys
would get back
and um
i know i had um before you jump into
that i had
one of my guys ryan jobe who uh
was shot in the face he was blinded
um and i'm talking to him you know he's
back
he's at i think he's at bethesda and i'm
talking to him from ramadi
and you know he's begging me to come
back
and he says you know sir i'll get my pig
he's a pig gun he's a 60 gunner he goes
sir give me my pig
don't worry i might not be able to see
him but i can smell him
i'll get him and and you know there's
just the the attitude
and and same thing with the first guy
that i had that got badly wounded
a guy named cowie cowie and
cowie was you know we know if he's going
to keep his leg but he was shot up bad
he's on
morphine or whatever he's on and we've
been in ramadi for
a very short period of time at this
point and i get to the
to the to the uh charlie med the field
medical area
and i roll in there and he's
you know he holds out his hand and and i
grab his hand and he like pulls me in
close
and he just whispers he's you know sir
let me stay
i'll sweep up just please let me stay
don't send me home and and you know
here's a guy
that's a freaking incredible athlete
incredible guy
and we don't know if he's going to keep
his leg and the only thing he cares
about
is you know can i stay
right yeah and this again
it seemed like it was of course just a
soft guys just saw it again and again
with all the guys that we encountered
but this one particular
visit i had up to walter reed i'd come
up see some of our kind of soft guys
rangers and
and others who'd been wounded and couple
again and of course walter reed was
where we sent the
frankly the most seriously injured
certainly the the blast victims and the
uh
and the amputees the barn victims
generally went to uh down fort sam
but i'm up there visiting a couple of
guys and talking to them them and their
wives and everything and you know
you know how to talk to these guys
they're guys that that are our rangers
or delta operators or seals and
and and that particular day i there are
three or four of them there and then
afterwards a sergeant major who's
escorting me around says hey so there's
somebody else i'd like you to meet
he's not a soft guy he's with the 25th
infantry division and he was in iraq in
a vehicle vehicle got hit by an
explosively formed projectile
he is a quadruple amputee
and i said absolutely i'd love to go
meet him so i go up to the
to the second floor of the rehab center
there i see the young man
standing off to the side he's kind of
leaning up against the rail and of
course
he's only about yay big because he's got
no legs and so i come over
to talk to him and i kneel down so i can
kind of get eye to eye with him and
i know what to say i mean what do you
tell a young kid who's
lost both his legs all of one arm and
most of the other arm
and so i'm i'm trying to make some small
talk i mean he obviously
saw something in my eyes you know the
pity of remorse or something
and he turns to me he says sir i'm 24
years old
i'm going to be just fine i never forgot
that
i'm 24 years old and i'm gonna be just
fine and all he wanted to do was
this unit was still in iraq and he said
can you
get me back to hawaii so i can be there
when the 25th infantry division comes
back
so i think we can manage that and we did
and he was able to get there and meet
his unit when they came back
well outstanding that's um and that's
you know
again a lot of the book is obviously
focuses around special operations and
and as you point out as we both know the
the
the sacrifices absolutely made by the
entire
the entirety of the the us military
um is just it's it's incredible it's
incredible and the bravery
the bravery doesn't the bravery doesn't
stay in one unit it's in all these units